you know Wayne Johnson still busy
working he just wrapped Jumanji with
Kevin Hart and you know once the rock
was named sexiest man alive I demand a
recount
you know and that heard it was close I
heard he edged me out by half a point
and you know what it's it's fine you
know it's it's it's fine he needed it
more than that day you know I mean every
day is a sexy day for me oh you were so
close all we love about Kevin is that he
always takes the high that's enough
ladies and gentlemen get a good look at
this face and that didn't sexy mouth I
don't know the meaning they were wearing
Oh Kevin's not letting the loss slow him
down he's in New York spreading some
holiday cheer for fans signing his music
one headphones I'm in a position where I
can provide for others and put smiles on
people's faces
it's about joy bringing joy to others
but that joy doesn't currently extend to
the kitchen I wish I could cook I can
boil a hot dog that's about it just
leave the cooking to the pros you made
more than 80 million dollars last year
you can hire a chef
[Music]
you